hey welcome everyone to another episode
of rent cafe episode 36 I'm Ana Mack
your host here for anime uproar and if
you're new to this whole thing this is a
weekly anime podcast that we have every
Thursday 5:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
where we talk about all sorts of anime
related topics we have a bunch of guest
youtubers and other anime experts and we
talk with you guys in the chat have a
great time hanging out last week I asked
you guys can we beat the previous week's
like record and we beat it we got like
145 likes thank you so much let's see
how many we can get this week drop a
like if you like Grand Cafe and let me
know let us know how much you like this
this week we're gonna be talking about
guilty-pleasure anime and we got a
star-studded cast here with us we got
anime recon what's up man what up my
boys if anyone knows what a guilty
pleasure is it's our boy anime Rico I
know I know I know what all of you are
gonna say I'm gonna try and be calm I
know what everyone's gonna say people in
the chatter like Anna Boch new here I
just slipped the bad guys it's the same
i just.back going for that Eastern
European style you know I mean okay
enough of that Joe Joe talks too much
we'll talk man hey man how's it goin
thanks for having me back always
appreciate it
oh oh it's great to have you the Grand
Cafe is always a pleasure for me to do
but it I couldn't do it without you guys
without you know the guests so we have
other ones do with just me talking and I
feel like I would get very awkward so
thank you for being here
Knox taco is back for the second time
what's up Knox
hello good nothing much
enjoying the rant cafe of course thank
you thank you for those guys I think
everyone here does I hope slows I hope
you guys and we also have soul ma come
back again what's up man hey everybody
back again let's do this nice and by the
way while people are coming in as
knocks recon soul and maybe even Jojo
eventually we'll know our discord server
is an amazing discord server and we
right now we're running contests a flag
contest designing the official and map
or flag if you're interested in
something like that
check out the discord link in the
description and there is also an
upcoming contest that's going to be
coming up with the best anime idea so a
story idea for an anime about a one page
idea and the best ideas are gonna be
discussed live on a special episode of
rant cafe so if you wanna take part in
the contest and then maybe have your
story discussed you are dear friend me
discussed by us I'd ran cafe again check
that out link in the description my god
our critics you're gonna be a critic
some of us are just you know by default
being on YouTube yes it's true and
knocks our boy NOx likes to do his
sarcastic anime trailers and he did a
sarcastic facts video both sort out
online last week I talked about it in
the news video and then recounted a lot
of reaction to that video both of those
videos are hilarious I highly recommend
it check out there any questions any
questions oh man what would that be
fight okay so the first question you
don't mind just when I mentioned Yui
that he could have saved all the players
instead of just saving Yui who's you
know once you come down to it she is a
program yes a very you know touchy-feely
emotional program but you said screw all
the other players because we don't even
know that of course you should save Yui
yeah that's right maybe the first maybe
storytelling why's that makes sense but
as far as the hero goes that's pretty
much the opposite kind of makes him a
giant I think you is more important than
the other people why would why would we
say that we don't know them they're not
they're not important for us viewers so
what the wonderful because as human
beings we tried to save people even if
we don't know them now I'll go for you
[ __ ] the other guys haha my Creed in the
man he says is sort out online
considered a guilty pleasure anime yes
it is yes yeah most definitely
recon will not agree but and by the way
my Creed is a guy who honest channel
does awesome orchestral compositions of
like anime openings and stuff like he's
a really smooth freakin composer and
musician I didn't even know I just saw
him on discord and I and I was like hey
this guy's a YouTube channel
he has like almost 20,000 subs and I
checked him out and he's like a great
musician man which is awesome cheers to
my Creed and of course I'm subscribed to
him now so I'll be following him closely
a lot of other recognized Ryan Toya Luna
mega I saw wicked Wiz caster for life
I saw a lovely tune Darrin Anna enol
girl bro Kaija Emilia Lausanne booth so
many cool thieves welcome everyone and
yes we could start with Sao guys I think
it's awesome week on clean recon claims
that SEO is a quality anime not a guilty
pleasure anime but I'm sure a lot of
people would say that you know it's
something to watch for but certainly not
for the plot or the quality is just
something because what guilty-pleasure
enemy is you know it's not a high
quality anime but you watch it because
it's like you know relaxing or it's just
fun or just funny but you don't get any
higher pleasure out of it other than
just entertainment in the most nice form
yeah personally I thought that I still
had a lot of cool concepts even Yui as
an AI I thought was an interesting
concept introducing that however again
the question is did they do it the right
way and probably not but you know I
don't all hate Sao but some who else
wants to Jojo I don't I want you to get
in on this I want you to tell us what do
you think what I say oh and then you can
transition into some guilty pleasure
anime other ones you want to bring up
okay um I okay Sao uh I don't want to be
mean cuz like but I kind of have to cuz
considering the show we're talking about
so I I'm kind of notorious for not
liking East Sakai stories but I will say
at the very least sao is entertaining in
like movie kind of sense like those
summer blockbusters that don't
necessarily like if you think about it
too much it kind of falls apart that's
how I feel about I say oh we're like if
I think about it for even like a second
it falls apart the story doesn't really
hold up the characters are kind of bland
but watching it as in particular that
first arc it's really fun it's a fun
show and in the first arc and then the
second arcs real bad cool if that's what
you're into I don't like guns in general
so it kind of just bored me
unless you're Clint Eastwood I don't
care and then the basement and the the
arc after that with Excalibur's real DOM
super pointless but that show like to me
sao has moments where it's really good
like mother's rosario which i think is
actually just a good story
so I think sao has every opportunity to
be good it just doesn't take it because
it knows it can coast because it had
like that first season in terms of story
and character is so whatever but people
blew the hell up like it everybody blew
it up that they know that they can kind
of throw whatever out there and it just
sticks so I don't necessarily think it's
a good show but I do enjoy parts of it I
enjoy like the the action the honestly
kind of the stupid logic is funny
sometimes like the magic bullets that
flies across the room through the
ethernet cable and shoot some dude a
like that kind of [ __ ] cracks me up
buzz moments I will say Jojo that I will
still prefer Kitty toe to a whole bunch
of crybaby protagonists so that is one
yes good thing about my character might
be Opie but at least I'm not listening
to him whine about how he's useless
for 25 episodes before he actually does
something worthwhile I feel like that
was a shot at someone in particular
there there's a bunch like the word
might think the worst and
is Renton Thurston from arica seven like
the worst we have no idea where she
likes Erica seven terrible terrible
pacing for a stroll I don't know if he
maybe read the manga future by the way
midnight highschool DxD as a great you
know guilty pleasure anime which I think
the recon would again argue that it's
just a brilliant brilliant anime Android
is said that my hair currently is
slicker the majority of anime
protagonists and I tend to agree I you
had a new thing that I am anime
protagonist material guys I've always
thought I'm personally a recon let's go
to you look for an highschool DxD
guilty-pleasure anime or something more
what why would DSD be a guilty pleasure
cuz it's bad no it smells it's not a bad
show it's a [ __ ] fantastic show
probably one of the best harem edgy
shows I've ever seen mm-hmm how many of
you seen oh yeah the new ones every
season I've watched all of them on watch
the OVA and watch I've watched
everything I'm currently waiting for the
fourth season I mean I mean racism bed
right now man I've got a body of memory
as I sleep with every [ __ ] night fair
enough
by the way yeah well that proves it's a
good show yes it does yes I guess for me
for me my guilty pleasure would be a
kiss excess there we go
we had kisses also brought up by joshie
tough knee and that's something else
here Lucario
come with my hair thank you and someone
else doubled the rebel said he likes Sao
to my boy recon so you have like one
person who agrees with you no I'm pretty
sure a lot of people agree but they're
just not saying it I'm pretty sure the
just yeah I don't judge people for
liking bad anime like mega my boy mega
great guy he says he thinks Erica 7 is a
good anime it is that's nonsense it's
crazy it's the worst painting I've ever
seen
any enemy right terrible so long as
speaking of people who like that enemy
soul maka how about you give us a
definition of in your opinion what
guilty-pleasure enemy is because we have
to we have some disagreements here with
recon for example not saying that
highschool DxD is a guilty pleasure and
I'm Aiman the most people say man is
just like edgy boobs there's you know
that's all it is for is just a guilty
pleasure so what do you think soul is a
guilty pleasure anime in your opinion
well in my opinion a guilty pleasure
anime would be an anime where
universally or a majority of people who
have seen it can all agree that it's bad
but you know there's something in it the
brings you some kind of enjoyment or
something you just like about it and so
you continue to watch it that's what
I'll call a guilty pleasure that's true
agree with the majority of people
business but I don't know I feel like
everyone for themselves should be able
to tell if the anime is stellar or not
so stellar yeah well I would say other
people have to come into it because
otherwise if it was just subjective then
none of recons like would ever be a
guilty pleasure because subjectively
two-hitter not bad for him so like her
name it would be a guilty pleasure
whereas for someone else it would not be
a guilty pleasure no no it'd be top of
people would think of it as a guilty
pleasure but we con wouldn't because he
thinks they're good yeah exactly the
right sure I don't feel charged bad
I think it's a good show so he's guilty
pleasure for recon whereas me it
definitely is yeah yes yes so basically
a guilty pleasure I think in my opinion
would be an anime that you know is no
masterpiece you know however you still
enjoy watching it just for laughs or
just for a Qi or whatever you know
you're only enjoying it on a certain
level you're not you know you're not
saying oh there's all this subtext to it
you know there's so much I can talk
about about this anime it's just it does
one thing but it does it in a way that
you enjoy it like for example with me
and Kay Jo
huge fan of cage oh not because I think
it's a masterpiece anime or a social
commentary or I think that just because
I think it's a hilarious anime parody of
sports anime of the etches onra and it
knows what it is
it doesn't take itself too seriously
it's it has some great humor in it humor
that is very much in line with the whole
otaku lifestyle and you know trends and
I mean really spoke to me and I loved it
for that reason and again I wouldn't
vote for it as best anime in any award
show but I would definitely watch more
of it and enjoy watching it while I
watch it by the way girl bro donated $2
to say when are we getting an animatic
buddy below two million subscribers body
pillow will happen you have my word
I love it great you stole mine by the
way mine was gonna be caged oh I was
like [ __ ] I'm all about talking about
cages as far as Kate Joe goes it's an
edgy anime done right more than almost
any other one that I've seen more than a
high-school dxd not that it's better
necessarily cuz I wouldn't say it is
better but it knows what it's doing with
the ecchi better it's not just you know
naked people walking around because
money yeah yeah knocks we seem to a lot
of similar opinions and exactly for me
Cage was hilarious because it knows what
it is it doesn't take itself too
seriously and at least it has some
pretense of a reason for why we're gonna
get you it's a sport it's played a
certain way this is what they dress like
and that's why it is rather than just
now I have crazy butt muscles exactly
rather than having you know I'm a anime
that just includes random panty shots
and stuff like that right that's my
least favorite type of ecchi anime
random and crammed in everywhere which
for me by the way no game no life it's a
perfect example of an anime we're
actually
completely contrived they just had you
know they have wrecked and
for no reason just to troll um she
doesn't fall from the plot it's not
creative not that in a creative way it's
just like there so that to me it's like
you know it's over the top it's like it
takes me out of the experience because
I'm like oh man you know they're
pandering such an obvious extent it's so
blatant yeah as I said my guilty
pleasure would be kissing says I know
it's bad it's bad overall I don't know
why I I just pretty much enjoyed it
overall I mean it's not the greatest
thing of course and pretty a lot of
people do agree but for some reason it
had that enjoyment that kept me watching
it I couldn't get through it I haven't
seen it yeah oh yeah Jojo you watch it
go ahead I mean you're not missing
anything anything yeah but it's just
about two cute girls who are in love
with their [ __ ] brother they're not
blood-related by the way it's not
related long as that's specified in the
song even if in the Japanese it's not
they just do weird stuff like [ __ ]
doing your stuff to a body pillow in
chocolate lipstick ups right
once you're talking about incest my
guilty pleasure anime I would have to
say my number one guilty pleasure anime
would be or emo why I happened to love
that show it's amazing even though I
know it's crap and that's what a guilty
pleasure is I enjoyed it the entire way
through
I loved the Molalla female characters
pretty much I loved Korean echo and I
loved you know Quirino the interactions
between the characters were fun but
all-in-all I know that the anime was
pretty terrible the ending as well the
ending was a disaster and I loved it -
guilty pleasure oh and another
interesting definition thanks NOx
guilty pleasure would be which anime do
you love and enjoy watching but would be
way too embarrassed to show either your
parents or coworkers or you know college
mates or something like that that it's
like I love this anime but I will not
want people to know that I watch this
anime anime like that for you guys any
let's say yeah girl character that the
jiggle physics happening and it's the
most embarrassing thing on the planet
actors not moving and their boobs are
it's not good it's windy okay he'll win
Seoul you were gonna say something yeah
well I was gonna say if we feel that
waist that's strongly about the anime I
don't think we're gonna expose ourselves
here yeah that's true Nick victory fire
brought up the one anime that for me
this season has been definitely a guilty
pleasure hajimeta nogal yep I have
watched it because Jo Jo recon first and
then Jo Jo told me to watch it I wanted
the first two episodes like yes this is
funny even though I think the friends
who like lollies are gross and should
get some help the main protagonist is
hilarious because believe it or not
ladies and gentleman that is exactly how
men actually think it's things is
exactly how men actually think I'm sorry
ladies if you are disappointed yeah
those the main dude at like okay uh
there's problems I have with hajimeta
no-go all of a sudden because it's like
a [ __ ] the manga it was like no don't do
that but they did anyway um connected oh
no we're talking about her econ in the
chat what the hell is going on
there's two there's two out what is not
one gonna be like like the evil twin
who's like Sao sucks and I know it I
think this is an ego issue he's feeling
outnumbered
have no idea what's going on there's two
of you man - an American account
yeah I don't know why I don't know
either bad just [ __ ] leave you crazy
oh we could just say that he is my my
clone brother I say opinion is opinions
in the tribe to NeoGeo welcome guys
um wolf horn is there as well
Ryan my sty ryan earlier uh okay yeah so
hundred oh yeah pretty hilarious I'm
enjoying it so far however I watched the
Centaur anime the life that was centaur
whatever after Jojo told me to watch it
and I thought that anime was too much
pandering like it was in many ways like
no game no life it was just a lot of
like Yuri for the sake of Yuri bait
it wasn't like really called for by the
plot in my opinion was just kind of like
oh here's some Yuri you like that don't
you like that and then it was a bunch of
like you know just otaku related you
know pandering so to me it didn't really
grip me that anime another anime though
that I continued to watch which is
pretty much a guilty pleasure - is [ __ ]
a GUI I continue I don't know why I
continue to watch it it makes no sense
in terms of the whole gambling thing it
makes no sense in terms of the you know
contrived I don't understand why you
don't understand the story it makes
perfect sense to me it doesn't make
sense because in knowing all that you
will never have a school based on
gambling like that's not legal
that'll never happen but I think it's
because the characters are so insane
that I'm like what is gonna happen next
also blue lipstick girl is best girl and
yeah I don't know I mean I'm hoping that
the whole thing is some kind of social
commentary on capitalism I don't know
what I continue her face is up can I
mention the smartphone anime real quick
oh yeah go ahead
I love that [ __ ] I so again so I'm not a
big east KY fan I really don't like that
genre I think it's real dumb doesn't
make any sense
I watched the smartphone anime out of
like sheer curiosity is to be like let's
just make fun of it I just want to make
fun of it at a good time making fun of
it and then it got a bunch of dislikes
and that made me go oh okay now it's on
and so now I watch it every week good
time can I mention it'll manga sensei
I've never seen it look so stupid that I
have not yeah it is you're a lucky man
anime but you watch the 2 bucks I've
watched it it's over did you like it is
it was it a guilty pleasure for you it
was written by the same person that
wrote Ori emo so I was expecting it to
be a guilty pleasure animes but it don't
mailing and sweetly if you saw the
ending the audio was also there all the
characters yes I did see and that was
probably the best part in the entire
thing I mean the whole thing was just
about she just wants to [ __ ] his little
sister basically that's it that's about
it he wants to become a the greatest
author and they have a brother and
sister relationship and he was so [ __ ]
that's it
I mean he's and everyone's a Lally yeah
all that lovely stuff rather than guilty
but right I mean this sounds like a just
a terrible terrible freaking enemy well
it is a bad show but I would say what
kept me in is because of the enjoyment I
just wanted to see what's gonna happen
what's gonna happen okay what's gonna
happen is he guilty pleasure enemy yes
it was a guilty pleasure for me
you also continued watching freaking
hand shakers didn't you yes that was
also working for a lot of people and for
me but I just I liked it I don't know
why because of the animation was just so
eye-catching so I decided to continue
what do you like everything that's
animated nicely if it's animated nicely
it's good across the board well hand
shakers is animated mostly but for me
that didn't answer the question well say
it again do you like any anime if it's
animated nicely it depends do you like
token ranbu
I do yes I do tails is exterior yes I do
okay fine there we go
I love the tension between NOx and recon
I know the sword art online sarcastic
facts video by Knox and scathing
response by I think we they say yeah he
is my biggest rival it's true and I
think that the next step guys is a
freestyle battle both both of you
participated in the cypher challenge
anime cyber challenge both did well so I
think that the next step in this is just
to crush each other some freestyle rap
battle about Sao and whatever else you
want to talk about I think that would be
excellent excellent start some scarce
I don't consider us rivals right rivals
have to by definition during the same
category or the same like you know
general League oho well I consider
myself an analyst or a critic
I consider recon a reactor or a top 10
compiler which he is that's what I said
and thereby you know he likes everything
which is great but my job is not to do
that so it's an unfair comparison I can
dogs face and JoJo's camera right now
yeah that's my dog yeah JoJo's got dogs
he's got skeletons he's got everything
he's like one of the most interesting
guests you can have one she was hence
the name literally crying at the door
the whole time Jojo yes yes it's so
bizarre over here also yeah shout out to
lump King and gray
over there in the chat t4z k3r is in
there two guys it's hard for me to shut
you out when you have such complex names
bTW does saying pride is there um yeah
so I think I think you guys got to do
that freestyle battle also recon you do
really nice quality top tens but how can
you include Eromanga sensei in your top
10 anime of 2017 why like I said romance
right it was enjoyable but wasn't that
all BAM
mending it for people to check it out
just just want to see what their take is
on it that's it even though I did I did
put it I'd I put it on like there below
the top five so yeah it's not it's not
in the top five its below the top five
so yeah just out of curiosity can you
name your top five really quickly a
whole time know of that video I don't I
don't wanna embarrass you too much watch
it
alright smell after but then I have to
wait a whole week gonna have to watch it
and find out all right you got it
and then measure dicks and the world was
happy they don't even show their face
isn't streamed the very yeah too scared
by the way Knox when is I'll talk with
on you're going right yeah August 4th to
6th Montreal cool week or so dr. Tommy
Moe hey al is that correct
I kept Maria I don't know there's just
tension between me between you and me
nooks I feel this I consider as great
friends just you better taste if you
guys knowing and recon freestyle battle
slash fight each other to the death in
boxing it drop a like on this up so
getting back to guilty pleasure anime
thank yous to be here uh has have any of
you guys seen air gear at all no yeah
yeah yeah I know the monk is amazing but
yeah I can't say the same for the enemy
yeah the anime kind of craps the bed
unfortunately I um when I got back into
enemy I was asked to be part of like a
Soul Eater cosplay group so I got in
back in into anime through Soul Eater
and then I started watching anime on
Funimation so I was like well what show
should I watch to get like I like I love
Soul Eater I'm just gonna go to the
first thing I see and that was air here
and all my friends are like oh so you
probably hate anime now I was like no
it's actually I kind of dig it
I like how over-the-top goofy it is like
it doesn't take itself seriously I like
the idea of like magical rollerblades
that make you fly
I like the stuff about it that I think
is really fun and cool and I'd like to
see like a I've said this about Soul
Eater and I'll say this about Air Gear
of all things I totally like to see like
a brotherhood where they're like at
we'll just do the manga for real this
time
I think that'd be cool would you
consider Soul Eater to be a guilty
pleasure no I actually like Soul Eater
right that's good yeah the my enemy oh
well obviously the monk is always Mother
mangas way better than anime the anime
end didn't was a bit I well put I
remember when I saw what first time I
was like I accept this like I guess like
I was like alright and over time like it
grew on me in the sense of like that's
the ending that he had to make because
they didn't know where the manga was
going I'm fine with the ending I'd like
it to actually have like a proper
adaptation but you know for what it is I
really really like Soul Eater alive
Excalibur's best girl Excalibur zone
Excalibur's a guy and he's got kids and
a wife so and for me for guilty
pleasures I don't know their series like
Kanak on yes
yeah the stories is yeah the story is
prophetic same like misty of wonder it's
done by the same people
ladies versus Butler's which again is
you know it's just stupid forced
situation just for the whole aichi
really but you know it has funny moments
in it yeah and then another one I did
enjoy by ain't that great really is the
familiar of
0o i don't know if you guys seen that
one you know yeah yeah look out Louise
yeah no yeah it's well it's not that
great
like story-wise and stuff I don't think
yeah I mean so you know but yeah it was
it was enjoyable we had the enjoyable
moments especially during the second
season I'd say more so with Cano con you
mentioned I watched the first five or
seven I don't remember episodes of Cano
Khan and then I was like why am I
watching this I just turned it off and
ran away I somehow got that far and it
still scares me how yeah it's nothing
but actually really that's all is this
you saw these four sections and stuff
but there's oh no there's humor in it in
how how like bold to go is like and you
just like attack the guy in the street
you know even though there's like other
kids and people walking by gee she just
totally doesn't care you know and then
something would happen in the old gal
exposed and then like the class
president will catch them and then
choose like she'll start cracking up and
then her friends will like dub the guy
king of hg and stuff so yeah I mean oh
those funny moments but yeah I'm gonna
say that the guilty pleasure for this
season this new anime season I think it
has to be our girl no I wouldn't say
that's funny
it's just humor it is funny I know
science it's story wise it's love that
gray I mean it's at the banana one I
mean it's very enjoyable yes for me
hajimeta no girl and kakigori for
different reasons probably but yeah just
want to say devil the rebel donated two
pounds just to say and among us sensei
the only good thing is the ending dance
I'd say the only good thing is the Digi
bro videos
cook making fun of the do bro videos we
all know that's what it was because we
are having Jojo you said something about
the whole concept like into one anime
air gear I think you said we're like
rollerblades make me fly yeah yeah yeah
so I haven't seen that anime but one
thing that some anime can do really well
is take an insane concept like that and
make it really cool for example
assassination classroom completely silly
premise you know
octopus monster teacher going to destroy
the world the students are all assassins
it's like you you you pitch that in a
Hollywood movie or something they're
like you're insane good idea exactly
whatever anime can sometimes pull it off
assassination classroom absolutely they
pull it off it's hilarious it's an
awesome show however a lot of the times
they fail miserably and many of those
can be guilty pleasures or can be just
bad overall another interesting anime
like an edgy anime girls Bravo like I
wanted that to be like a guilty pleasure
but I couldn't really you know put up
with it like there was funny moments but
you know protagonist is a photo crybaby
who is literally allergic to girls and
yet all these girls love him he has like
a harem of girls like crazy about him
there's nothing good about him as a
person he's a crybaby like oh he's
terrible and yet all these girls love
them and it's just like yeah I realize
it's in some ways it's parroting tropes
but just like you can't enjoy it even as
a guilty pleasure so that's the problem
with some of these anime not guilty
pleasures another guilty pleasure that
I'd like to bring up is fairy tale to
anyone who likes it yeah your boy right
here I haven't really a fairy tale fun
I've seen a couple episodes and I don't
really think fairy tale I like the arcs
that are done well I think the grand
imaginative games forever arc is one of
the it's like a really top tier shown in
arc but as far as all the interactions
between the the family of the guild of
fairy tale oh I really loved all of
those moments even though I know that
fairy tale is a rather cringy the
Kurt Howse a cringy my fairy tale have
you seen Matt - no Natsu and Lucy not
soon was a Opie character how was he
cringy not Sue's not Opie he is the end
of every AR he's weaker than Ursa and
then at the end of every arc he'll eat
some crazy nano a theory on something
and get way crazy powerful for like ten
minutes
wreck the main bad guy and then go back
to same old nuts it I just bought half a
fairy tale he's nuts
way to ruin it for me sorry well good I
love fairy tale I still haven't watched
dragon cry because I cannot find it
anywhere though dragon crack dragon cry
the movie it's like a oh yeah I didn't I
didn't get into a fairy tale enough I
can see it it's like it has some
interesting action and some interesting
characters and fanservice then I can see
that only as a guilty pleasure anime so
I see your point there Knox
somebody that I mentioned High School of
the Dead and yes that is a perfect
example of a good guilty pleasure anime
I mean there is you can talk about
certain things there like how its
parodying the whole zombie genre it
includes direct references to like Night
of the Living Dead and like it zombie
classics mm-hmm
so there is something there but then
also look the crazy over-the-top patchy
the jiggle physics the insanity of the
situation putting you know so much Aichi
in a harem a chi in the context of a
zombie apocalypse like it is a guilty
pleasure but there it's it's a good
guilty pleasure yeah that's tender rock
on is there like next week's boob yeah
bullets exactly most famous yeah Luna
just asked me if I'm sad the fairy tale
is ending yes of course I'm sad that
fairy tale is not gonna continue why
would I be [ __ ] happy everyone who
hates
fairy tale is probably so happy it's
ending but yeah no one's happy it's
anything as much detective I own you not
like the whole world is against you
recon
oh yeah a lot of people are against this
specifically the SEO haters if you don't
know I won against you I literally
changed my name in discord since this
anime are you gonna [ __ ] all SAO haters
in brackets that is how dope he is he's
savage exactly heaven
he's like Jay Paul yeah god damn it I
was gonna reference some of the guilty
pleasures I like his uh try Ajax which
is done by the same people that did High
School of the Dead and months from
assuming I'm awesome soon a fun times I
love I love the white foods like how
they are stuff to different characters
they are I mean they're great you know
all the different females are coming to
a great well obviously you know plot
wise story was just it's complete crap
but you know is still fun it's a fun
show totally all right how about blue
exorcist season 1 did you consider that
a guilty pleasure huh I liked the first
15 episodes of blue exorcist very mode
for me the first season didn't appeal
too much but the second one was great
but the first 15 episodes are pretty
great I thought that the whole blue
exorcist stuff was man it wasn't like a
guilty pleasure but it wasn't bad it was
just kind of like whatever although I do
think that Mephisto is an interesting
character he's the most interesting
character to me what is the OP - I don't
know it's all of those weird gay clown
characters that are just so awesome
Hisoka from Hunter hunter the guy is
amazing just because they're gay knocks
first of all okay so why are they all
chasing little kids well boys I mean
little boys any common phobia on this
channel man I feel welcome here
by the way what George are you a secret
clown because Jojo is a good name for a
yes
secretly all this time didn't you see
Mike the trailer for my new movie it
that's me
Oh Jojo just creeped out a lot of people
I bet I did
big-time we asked an interesting
question our parody anime
guilty-pleasure anime and now personally
I think that they can be because if a
parity anime like high school the dead
and you know kono Tsubaki Joe shimonita
hmm yeah like they can be guilty
pleasure anima because they know what
they're doing like I said they they're
not they know that they're not gonna be
you know masterpieces of brilliance you
know brilliant award-winning anime but
they're funny they're parodying and
their guilty pleasures in that sense
like I said you're not going to do on a
big analysis essay necessarily on these
anime but you still enjoy them however I
don't you can have a parody anime that
is also beyond guilty pleasure for sure
like killa kill it parodies the high
school genre really well in parodies
actually really well and yet it has an
interesting plot it as I think in
interesting social commentary likes to
do trigger tends to really do a good job
way so you have to me that's an example
of a parody anime that includes that she
and all that crazy trope stuff and yet
is beyond just a guilty pleasure is an
actual quality quality enemy um I agree
with you with some and I disagree with
you with killa kill and kono Suba
because I think kono Suba is not a
guilty pleasure in anime and it's
actually a good anime it's doing well
like for example one punch man isn't a
guilty pleasure it's a good show it over
there it's a comedy and even if it is a
parody
killa kill I wouldn't even get I loved
I'll get I'll give you if you didn't
like it because you didn't get it knocks
that's what it is your analytical skills
failed you miserably yeah I probably
watched it before I went into the hole
and analysis things yeah now you must re
watch no you must
we watch and we know that will not
happen that will not happen we must go
into a showdown because by the way my
brother goes and also didn't get killer
kill you didn't understand the
philosophical aspects so I have to you
know I have to always listen for that
philosophical aspects of those
mother-daughter Bath sessions yes it's
one scene dude relax okay
also one scene where the daughter gets
finger-blasted by her mother yeah and
then the other girl gets raped biker
clothes fun stuff it's fine man listen
man like I said we can do a whole thing
on why killer killer is brilliant but
I'm gonna say that
quano supa I'll give you that it's not
necessarily just to give Lee Panama
because like you said for one contra man
- it's a parody that I really think is a
quality funny show not necessarily just
a guilty pleasure but there are people
who think that one punch man is just
like a one-note anime that it's just one
joke that gets old so for them if they
watch it it might be just a guilty
pleasure they're watching it for the
funny action whatever not because
they're actually thinking about it in an
analytical level I think recon deserves
credit for mentioning shimoneta because
I actually agree with him finally Wow
it's been an hour and a half of rant
cafe and I agree with him six minutes oh
by the way uh Maria Eddings shout out to
her let me know is in the chat - she
Minetta is just all about [ __ ] [ __ ]
is just deadly anywhere for me it was
pretty bad but that's tough to say I
know was the only thing that kept me
interested in that show which one was
that
shamone no no which who's Anna I don't
all right a psycho
yeah the cost class presidents what was
what did the name of that show maka you
should totally know this one Landry con
2 was the name of that showed the really
edgy one that the class president that
was forced to marry the dude oh oh
okusama oh that's it that one yeah
that's a guilty pleasure anime yeah I
preferred the manga I didn't I didn't
like the way the anime was done I
preferred the manga with that one yeah
try to think of like any other okay
guilty pleasure anime get rekt freak on
overlord
[ __ ] you man yeah okay so what was
likable about maka
your your analytical yeah yeah I don't
ya know but I don't get I want to know
your reasoning would you take let's take
eyes yeah yeah what's good about him as
far as character goes as far as
character goes oh no he was there for
jokes he's there to be Opie to be the
ruler but he's a comedy anime it wasn't
it was not to be you know I'll be toes
there to make yeah and when she's not
there
then there's just I'm wrecking
everyone's there's no from seam to seam
i I really liked it until like episode 3
I was really invested into overlord when
he summoned the black death knight fingy
and he killed out armies and whatever
but when when he's fighting an army of
these priests guys and they come up with
this massive ninth level angel that can
destroy all being holy magic and he
points at it and it dies or Clementine
or whatever her name is with the swords
you know what you're talking about
like every bad guy just was getting
hyped that they were really powerful and
then just sort of died in front of him
or there's a dog who likes one punch
one hunch man was funny and was a parody
of overlord No Overlord is good for the
following reasons
a it has a you're not your explanation
of why Owens is so overpowered he was
part of a different game and then he
goes into a world where actually the
magic of that game is op2 in this world
and he doesn't even believe in himself
he needs to realize that at first and
he's like oh [ __ ]
so it's explained well also I feel like
he's a relatable character because I
also want to be an emperor of the world
so I relate very much to him I like the
relatability as far as being an emperor
but this guy's trapped in a different
world now like many characters are at
these days and it's crazy overpowered
even if it's well explained the truth of
the matter is there is no challenge in
the universe rim to the fact that even
his maids can take down the most
powerful dragon enemies ever and he
doesn't want to go back his entire you
know purpose of being there is just
conquering places no yep go back he was
stuck in a shitty crispy it has a ninja
I'm stuck here he was stuck seen as an
interesting recon recon yeah it has an
interesting uh like political strategic
dynamic to it this anime because yes he
starts off in this world Opie with his
own like kingdom everything set up his
own like Opie warriors and yet he can't
just chill out and enjoy that because he
gets lured into the rest of that world
even though he doesn't know if there's
someone more powerful there than him he
could be exposing himself it's dangerous
he it's a mysterious world and he
doesn't know it but he realizes that he
sees people in danger and he's like oh
[ __ ] I gotta say though I feel guilty
but by doing that he exposes himself
then he's like okay I need to learn more
about this world or else I might be
caught off by surprise and someone could
actually get the best of me and you know
overthrow me or screw me over so I have
to now actually explore this world and
learn more about it so
interesting thing where you know even if
you're trying to be an isolationist and
trying to kind of just live on your own
you end up being dragged into the
world's affairs so it's an interesting I
think commentary on the whole aspect of
no man's an island and so in that sense
I really enjoyed that fair enough
although the world's affairs didn't seem
to affect him all that much I he got the
hamster guy that was pretty amazing
right well they did affect him when the
vampire go ended up getting yeah
possessed and and she'd end up turning
against him who was essentially his
weakness and he ended up having to fight
and killer so yeah I mean it does affect
him yeah but first of all the vampire
girl was working for him was one of his
servant creature thingies yeah oh the
only / the only ones that actually stood
a ghost of a chance against him and in
the end didn't even get close because he
can use all those mega weapon thingies I
was his own creation yeah
but then these other people also got
artifacts because that's what they had
to use to possess the vampire girl so
now he's worried because then his power
then becomes what matched or obsolete
depending on the artifact he's going up
against yeah so I think that Knox just
got owned I like that
like I'm curious like after all that
like what like Knox what do you like
what what was enjoyable to you
throughout the series cuz like that's to
me I find that [ __ ] more interesting
than like like the negatives like
positives I probably enjoyed it most
because the trapped in another world
genre while it's overused I like it
every time that genre is a guilty
pleasure genre for me and I like how is
sort of wrecked everyone even though
stupid for the most part the art and
animation was also brilliant and the
opening was catchy as hell oh yeah yes
very albedo is a great white
mmm yeah I mostly just like the
atmosphere in overlord I actually am
with Knux where I'm like asses guilty
pleasure for me I'm not crazy about it
but I like yeah I like the atmosphere I
think what's her face is waifu material
of it the highest caliber and yeah I
just I think the the main dude looks
friggin rad so yeah all right I'm glad
someone agrees with zai nob says it's
amazing look at anime upper line yes
this is me live this is me live guys
that's crazy oh how about surgical
behind no bahama huh
didn't like it no no what one what one
is the one with the cliche looking dude
and all the girls that freakishly love
them for no reason oh yeah again one
minute which one is it is it the one
with the guy honey has that black sword
and it calls up that black mech that you
can use yes that is that yeah that to me
that was it's the same like as infinite
stratos hundred and pack kind of crap is
is just recycled but you know elements
and I said but yeah yeah one special guy
surrounded by loads of girls got some
special mech power ability that's it
yeah fine so but sometimes I don't want
to twist guys can't have these powers
but only he does yeah yeah like how
infinite stratos was yeah infinite
stratos are Fafnir you watch them that
HS x h muscle gakuen thingy oh yeah yeah
that one yeah yeah yeah that's a whole
different level of that yeah yeah you
have a guy the only guy to have the
power but he can only use it to power up
girls by yes sexual confessor that's
creepy
no it's not a hentai but its board is
all important why would it not be it's
like if that's your plot just what I'm
doing not be here and don't know the one
that should be ahead Scott one that come
out this season Jesus Christ that should
even and tech yeah yeah guys oh my god
the guy whose dress which one the guy
who's just as a girl yeah yeah the five
Episode five minute film so I can't
speak to it but of course you know soul
and recon no exactly
no no no fan kambou Ambu was the one
hosting the stream he put on and I went
ready same as Nexus of time that's also
a guilty pleasure I like trying to have
your back here but no not that one that
you can't have that one I'm you know any
other one if you don't like a Joe Joe
I'm still watching it I know it's a
terrible no Joe Joe I don't care man I
love this why there's so much better
ones though harem King I have to watch
the my shows
then I wish you luck my friend Thank You
Jojo yeah [ __ ] - shut up - zero he's in
the chat - and gorgeous grown man um one
thing I want to say by the way of course
drop a like if you like rant cafe I see
a few people in the chat or mentioning
likings drop like if you like my cafe if
you want to see more I want to bring up
I want to just get it to kill a kill a
bit I feel like ranting about it I feel
like you know taking it to Knox the
reason kilakila so brilliant like on the
once on one hand it absolutely has your
guilty pleasure qualities right so it
has the over-the-top
action over-the-top setting over the top
art which is near a studio trigger
classics but I feel like it works really
well the way to do it it has you know a
chi it has all the stuff to make it a
you know a guilty pleasure animate I
feel like this would be much better if
you made a separate rant cafe episode on
why I hate studio trigger your labor
raping arithmetic and you should have a
intervention Ren cafe what we say that
Knox taco has lost his damn mind as long
as I take sugar has done some bad stuff
though like that freaking ninja Slayer I
mean that was ninja Slayer was the worst
animated anime I've ever seen I mean
you've got Astro Boy that Rockets past
it everything they do is great however
kill a kill is great because like I said
on top of all of that it has very cool
characters again that cool characters
could just be a guilty pleasure anime
however I think that the whole plot and
everything about it is very well
thought-out
it is a critique the whole clothes on
taking over clothes being something
alien coming in and taking over people's
minds literally is embodies is a clear
social commentary on consumerism
so the idea of I read my fair
philosopher jean-jacques Rousseau talks
about a more proper a more proper is
love of self that depends completely on
what others think of us so the
difference between a more proper animal
de soir is a mood as far as you love
yourself based a lot solely based on
intrinsic love because you know that as
a person you deserve to be loved and you
love yourself it doesn't matter what
others think of you a more proper is a
type of law that only exists in society
where people compete with each other
where they want to look better compared
to each other where they look at what
others think of them clothes and fashion
is a perfect example of that people want
to show off by you know dressing better
have any higher fashion standards that's
a perfect example of that van
I'm more proper and this killer kill
gives us a world where alien things so
these clothes which are only which are
not natural to us the result would say
the natural man has no need from or
proper he only cares for himself at an
intrinsic way these things are
introduced these alien things and now we
start they start taking over our lives
that they start to you know affecting
how we think of each other how we think
of the world and in Coquille they
literally take over our brains and in in
killa kill nudist beach are the group
that are fighting against these and they
reject this and they go they just take
off their clothes they were jack natural
man type situation where they don't have
any clothes and they're like so epic and
fighting you know fighting going back to
the natural man and away from the social
corruption and I think that that from a
philosophical aspect is amazing I don't
think it's as good as Gurren Lagann
however I think it is still an amazing
animal you want me to come back now I
don't think you can come back after that
looks let me go I don't have something
prepared on everything goes written by
the Gurren Lagann
people like I don't have a little stack
of papers here ready Feist with ranch
separate for all these weird
out-of-the-box anime but as far as killa
kill goes I did not like the progression
at all for any of the characters except
for Sangha Yama
the blind guy yeah is that his name yeah
solid oh yeah you know I'm talking about
so I like that guy and honestly
guilty-pleasure characters I like tamaco
even though everyone seems to hate her
yeah I like to she was the best eyeful I
agree she was probably my favorite
character when she got close you know
key I hated my toy I hated both of them
they both had no reason to do what they
were doing and even the reasons that
they thought up of like oh I feel so
terrible for my father who I never liked
but now he's dead
so now I have to fight from sort of that
was sort of thrown in there just so she
can hate the entire school that wasn't
possibly say des Satsuki kiryuin does
not have more strong motivations the
sister the automation was right for what
she's doing so she's taking over all
these different schools through the
haunch in Academy and we think at first
she's working with her mother and she's
doing this you know to help her mother's
cause but in reality the reason she's
doing this is so she can create a force
a fighting force strong enough to oppose
her mother so she has a very very strong
motivation and I think that was done
brilliantly how they turn her from a
villain to an actual hero I think that
that was sort of done in one second and
she didn't need to make an enemy of Mata
to do it
that was just let's kill the newcomer so
the newcomer can be in terrible grief
and anguish for like 12 episodes until
we decide it's time to turn everything
around and find a new bad guy but I
disagree because the her approach is
survival of the fittest I need the best
the strongest to in order to oppose my
mother who I know is controlled by alien
creatures and is a monster is heartless
so we need to you know weed out the weak
and get the strongest and if that means
two young bees fighting tournaments and
you're challenging them and see if they
rise to the occasion then so be it
that's how we do it and again I totally
buy into it I totally buy it there was
no reason to have my toy fight all those
four general guys just so that she can
know that she's strong enough to help
her fight her mother now there was no
purpose to their sorry oh say again the
main character yeah it was for elites
yeah he's saying you saying like mucho
Annette Domingo never had to fight like
all of the generals just to test how
strong she was cuz at dinner end of the
day you've got other people that are
recruited that are like just like the
head of tennis club the head of boxing
club yeah
mean so if those people can get in why
shouldn't Muto what there's no reason to
make this whole situation so hellish for
her just so that oh you're strong enough
but I disagree again Satsuki's whole
philosophy is just that you have to in
order to fight these villains or Trump
take over the whole world these aliens
you have to be strong you have to
overcome you you know there's no messing
around here in Chinese and what they
were saying she was supposed to be doing
but it's like they thought of it at
episode 12 that even if they thought of
it from the beginning they said we're
not gonna we're not gonna give this away
she's gonna be such a great bad guy
until episode 12 and then everything's
gonna flip oh she was really doing
everything for the good of the world yes
and I loved it because I thought the
reasoning worked perfectly because we
don't know at the beginning we don't
know about home of her mother we don't
know how bad she is we don't know her
true intentions but as we learn then we
understand Satsuki's motivations more I
understand the motivations they were
trying to impose on her but it wasn't
done naturally well it's okay to
disagree with something I'll tell you
what you want me to rewatch it I'll do
it only if I can I'll rewatch it with
you one day one day well we'll just
we'll sit down and we'll marathon it no
I agree because I also I want to rewatch
and take some notes about the you know
the stuff I'm kind of just rambling
about I'm just remember it from watching
it but I want to take out some notes
maybe make a video on it too so that
would be useful I think for both of us
not I don't know about both of us I saw
it four years ago and I'm very happy to
not revisit that part of my life yeah
but then you're gonna revisit and be
like I've learned the truth that adamak
has trained me yeah and by the way
fanservice is what some of the best fan
service in any anime isn't kill a kill
yeah because fanservice is considered
armor and kill a kill it's beautiful
it's beautifully done it's it's just I'm
not gonna get into it but it's like if
this time it not worth the time at this
point but if you a fancier is much
rather have something like that in such
creative ways and there's an actual plot
justification for it then just girls
walking around oh look
panty shot for no reason because the
camera somehow moved under her skirt ok
so just because I agree with you at that
that doesn't mean that killer kills
genius I am NOT a fan of the panty shots
either we're not all recons but as
killing kill goes suspenders are not a
normal dress I wear suspenders yeah but
you're not naked under the suspenders
what they're not naked under my clothes
the reason they have to wear that is
because this clothes if you have more of
it on your if there's more surface oh
that falls over you it's more like you
for it to take over your body because
it's alien material so it's justified by
the little the less you have event the
better because it the less likely are to
be taken over by it so it justifies in a
hilarious way as much fanservice as
possible
Hey and one while while that's
completely brilliant and the creators
totally had to do that because otherwise
it would have been a plot hole it's not
armored though on the places that there
is no you know alien clothing and if
someone would get whacked in episode one
for example by this massive spikes
boxing glove it's not epic armor that's
blocking it we'll have to revisit this
knocks after we've both three watched it
because I think that we can both learn a
lot from rewatching it and then having
an awesome debate about it yeah maybe
but I'm still keen on this triggered
debate because I don't know kids neither
and Inferno cop and then just later was
actually good for me well I was a guilty
pleasure I loved it actually it was
really well done
III wouldn't put make it a guilty
pleasure either I didn't like it I'm a
big fan I don't know if you know the
best thing trigger put out in my opinion
yeah
the problem is I don't think I don't
defend every single thing studio trader
has done but there's a lot of great
anime that in the end the force to the
tiger you didn't like any of them
I really I didn't think any of them were
really quality he and Lulu Co yeah okay
but the rest of them are really not
special they didn't do anything special
ya see for me I have to disagree because
of kilakila especially but again that's
not the subject will have to revisit so
would you say that knocks - you killer
kill is just a guilty pleasure
nope Oh didn't enjoy it look up Lulu Coe
I enjoyed yay maybe guilty pleasure
maybe even boring decent anime okay what
do you think Jojo because I want
everyone to agree on things and be happy
we all like yeah and I'm waiting for a
Jojo Rance cafe also somehow most of you
haven't seen it Jojo the anime dodoo the
anime no just a whole rank if you just
send of--can yeah I could do it I could
fill up I could do it Nucks I'm waiting
for your a lor Khan fifty sarcastic
facts si oh okay speaking of alo arc
that's guilty-pleasure cuz I enjoyed it
and I know it wasn't that great
it wasn't it was a decent arc for me my
favorite was on crowd and you didn't
like Gigi oh I didn't think Gigi owes me
Singh was good I loved the pacing was
terrible they could have filled the
entire arc into four episodes and they
spread it over twelve or fifteen and
there was just so much trying to make
you Tito look awesome and smart because
he is awesome and smart and also that's
how I said chignon could not compare to
Astana so that was a drawback here's
what I'm gonna say [ __ ] see known love
much love for asana even my really
okay well as far as alo while it made no
sense that he went off track to save the
Kate shifts and to save the green people
and while it didn't really make sense
that he turned into Glee mais monster
you know what I'm talking about to fight
off the salamanders none of that made
any sense at all that was his power that
was his class that he chose the class
that he chose was able to make illusions
yes I'm making monster that was not an
illusion people with his claws know that
yes it was an illusion are we still
talking about the same show what the
[ __ ] he wasn't really stabbing them with
his claws he was using his sword but
people were thinking he was using his
claws that is what I was like eight
people at the same time guys you know
what my guilty pleasure is my guilty
pleasure is listening to Knox and recon
argue about that say Oh
agree I just I just some of the points
MUX said just oh it's so annoying and I
just have to fix it I shouldn't say more
just to save it for the alo 50 facts
because you probably make some really
solid ones I think I think that is table
bow needs to happen however we're gonna
have to start wrapping this up
ladies and gentlemen again if you like
right if they drop a light also if you
want to continue to conversation you can
join the discord server recon is there
now Knox is their soul maka always there
Jojo I don't know if you use this cord
but if you do you're welcome to come to
the discord
I shall not cool sounds good okay before
we wrap this up thank you everyone in
the chat for coming of course before we
wrap this up
tell us guys again of what you are what
you are who you do you know what I mean
starting with you what do you do and
what are you I am Knox and I do anime I
do analysis videos I do critique videos
and since I was starting to get a lot of
hate from people for critique videos
because I'm just so right with
everything and it hurt people's feelings
I
making sarcastic videos which honestly I
think are pretty hilarious and a nice
way to mask the critique in a sarcastic
way that people don't get that triggered
unless you recon onto your recon I
always go last no no you wanna go knocks
you definitely did have a good sense of
humor I have to give it to you you're
wrong and killer killed by you have a
good as a humor on other things so you
know you my boy soul do you if I make it
fifty facts on kill a kill if I make you
50 facts on killa kill will you live
react I will get triggered man
triggers see now you have the feelings
just as I just as I reacted to the
yellow one dude I I prayin it I'm all
like cool and stuff but if someone dis
the gory logon I would get [ __ ]
triggers like recon the way younger and
Hagen might be a thing if it's 50 facts
and why Gurren Lagann is brilliant and
it has a picture of me somewhere doing
something like this with you know
communist beside me and like some [ __ ]
then it's cool if it's critical in any
way Knox I'll be honest I was gonna make
a analysis video on Gurren Lagann
because I was looking into something and
it turned out to be pretty amazing and I
would really only do it if you live
react because it's not really getting
hyping out so I feel like I would
deserve it I will try to do a video on
Gurren Lagann as well and then we'll see
like hopefully within the next few
months and then depending on how that
does if you wanna then drop that in we
can tie in your fact video after and
then I can react to it and then we can
do an analysis about it on rank if
there's something to do a little tie-in
collab because I'm always down to talk
about Gurren Lagann but as you said
there's not that much opportunity
because there's not that much hype but I
would love to try to do something along
those lines so I was thinking within the
next few weeks my video may be coming
out because I was working on the script
just because I thought of something
pretty amazing I'm hyped up for your
fate one actually I don't I I just don't
know like because we have a big schedule
now me and goes and you
stuff we have to get out though I'm not
sure when I can commit to making but
it's definitely gonna happen the Holi
person I'm not I don't need you to
commit to do anything you're just to
react to this so I could see your face
like burst into tears because of the
awesomeness of this analysis okay well I
know but I'm thinking now you're gonna
talk about analysis I'm like man I
wanted to say that in mind already knows
let's go to Seoul Seoul mock-up who are
you and what do you do hey this is
amateur manga is a visual novel and
hopefully sometime soon my youtube
channel
yeah but for all intents and purposes
you can all find me on I'm Hannah max
discord so yeah you guys yeah and when
you do have a channel we will link it in
the description soul but for now we
cannot thank you Oh Jojo do we go to you
yet no Jojo don't think so hey everybody
I'm Jojo from Jojo talks too much
I am currently still doing free months
right now that's a thing I do series
called in a minute where I talk about
weekly anime sorry I
yeah weekly anime every single week in
under a minutes and then kind of a
little bit longer thanks to Anna Mac and
Briggs actually they helped kind of
shifts and admit it into what it is
currently so that's a thing and it's
good it's good I like to yeah
currently doing something regarding uh
currently working on a deaf no video
spoilers but that's the thing I'm doing
because that movies coming out yes nice
can't wait for that I I you know Death
Note is a great thing to talk about
people don't do it enough because again
it hasn't been acting you know current
for a while now with the movie it is a
good opportunity to talk about it
or so that's cool I'm up to bash light
whenever anyone wants to hear light get
destroyed just find me I'm also on
Animax discord I have a YouTube channel
nut stacker yeah Knox link in the
description to Knox Jojo recon and every
recon finally to you finally team cool
okay that's it
what up you know you know me this recon
I do them top tens I do them reactions
and I'm an SGA Aaron King and Knox taco
is my number one rival and yes I resent
them subscribe if you're new and yeah
hope you enjoy this is this Frank cafe
video
yeah everyone everyone subscribed to
these guys because they're gonna be
dropping some beef soon I can feel it
there's gotta be more beef coming so be
sure to stay tuned for that [ __ ] it's
gonna be fun
and as always guys thank you so much for
joining me my guests here in the stream
my people in the chat um all you guys I
appreciate it coming every week hanging
out with us it's such a blast always you
if you want to continue a conversation
another kind daily basis we do the
discord is always active there's always
stuff going on so you can join that link
in the description otherwise we're gonna
be bringing more content to you soon
rank up every week Thursdays 5:00 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time and until next
time see us bass cowboy I love you all